sin duda no fue una noche muy agradable
para quienes estábamos ayer en kiev a
partir de las dos de la madrugada
alrededor de esa hora empezaron a sonar
las alarmas y también un poco más tarde
se empezaron a oír explosiones en el
cielo que era trabajo de la defensa
antiaérea especialmente Desde esa
partería antiaérea Los Patriotas dados
hace poco por Estados Unidos y que han
cambiado realmente la dinámica de la
guerra y es que en la noche enviaron al
menos seis misiles hipersónicos que
hasta hace pocas semanas eran imposibles
de ser interceptados por Ucrania Pero
ahora con esta nueva tipo de defensa
antiaérea han logrado hacerlo Como lo
hicieron esta madrugada no sabemos
Cuántos misiles venían hacia aquí pero
sí sabemos que además de estos
hipersónicos lanzaron al menos nueve
misiles cruceros y otros tres misiles
balísticos tanto desde el mar como
también desde el tierra y esto venía
seguido por drones que también atacaron
no solamente kiev sino otras partes del
país todos fueron interceptados según
nos cuenta hoy el gobierno ucraniano sin
embargo lo que también han asegurado es
que la misión de este ataque era no
solamente poner en evidencia ese sistema
de defensa antiaéreo confundirlos sino
descubrir Cuáles eran las posiciones de
esta batería antiaérea patriota Así que
lo que nos cuenta hoy el alcalde de
jefes que el gran daño fino de esas
partes de los misiles y de los drones
interceptados que caían en la ciudad
algunos pegaron en algunos edificios en
algunos coches que prendieron fuego
también en el zoológico y tres personas
habrían quedado heridas